ten questions with kyle brent i'm the
ringer in spotify back here on the rich
eisen show how are you sir
rich in addition to a myriad of options
you present to your viewers and
listeners i'm on the peacock right now
i'm excited
i'm very excited you're on the quadcast
which is what i'm calling it kyle i
don't know who else is calling it that
but you know when you're on uh linear
cable
and streaming as well as satellite radio
and terrestrial radio there's just
there's just not enough ways for me to
disseminate pertinent information it's
essentially
fantastic i i've always wanted to share
the same vessel as uh the great kevin
costner which i do now
we're a yellowstone family and he also
can be seen
on the peacock so i'm fired up richard
look at you kyle there's no
i and kyle but there was a why but that
i don't know what that means
um so uh look
man as you know in this business uh when
you're asking questions
normally you you you'd like to know the
answer beforehand
um you did the head nod as kirk cousin
says if i die i die like he went uh
drago on you uh yeah what
that i mean that was quite something uh
what yeah
when did you interview him by the way
back um it goes back a few weeks rich
kirk is kind of an old buddy like we uh
we're both in chicago suburbs
we we have a lot of the same dad humor
so he
he came on and um we were taught we
stumbled into that topic that's not
something that i had in my bullet points
or my plan
questions or anything and we started
talking about you know because this is a
few weeks ago like i said
what do you think the facility is going
to be like kirk this is in this coronal
world and he said well you know i think
there's going to be a dichotomy of some
guys who couldn't carry less some guys
were really into it
and he mentioned something about masks
and so i just threw it out
out of left field i just said scale of
one to ten kirk everybody has a number
what's your mask sensitivity
are you a a one where you don't care and
think it's pointless or ten you're never
leaving the house again and you're
really nervous and he says
point zero zero zero zero one which i
was
really surprised by and i i think to
your great credit here rich on the show
with you and the staff i liked that you
played the full sound bite
because it's gotten real real quick baby
today
and it's just basically been boiled all
the way down to if i die i die which as
you said
the worst thing you want to give the
internet is a well-worn uh
ivan drago trope that they can run with
and photoshop her cousin's head onto
giant soviet shoulders so they've done
it
it's left the barn i was very surprised
at the time you said it because it's
kind of a hard quote to follow
i think his bottom line is i don't
really wear
masks for myself and i'm comfortable but
i do it
so that other people are comfortable and
that's how i get down i think that's
what he means yeah that's what he's well
i mean that's
and yeah it was one of those where i
didn't quite follow but we do know that
there's a large part of our population
that um is of mass averse
um and um i'm not one of them
and the the fact is is that the nfl and
the players association
have essentially been uh advocates for
wearing masks as has
pretty much anybody who's an athlete i
guess in many ways to make a living
because that's the way that we can
possibly
have sports so to hear somebody of
kirk's
stature say that it was a little jarring
to me i'm not going to lie but i was
at least pleased to hear that he said
and this is no virtue signaling or
anything like that and you've been very
you you had a video a couple uh weeks if
not a month ago talking about the
importance of mask wearing that went
very viral
um um if i'm not mistaken i was at least
pleased to hear him say that he he does
it for the comfort of others and also to
make sure that
he might not be inadvertently getting
anyone else sick
yeah i mean rich we have a big mass
household here we don't we don't leave
the house we don't get the mail we don't
do anything without it but i think you
tapped into what is really reverberating
with this
if an athlete just said something that
pissed people off that's a dime a dozen
and people
you know have their pound of flesh and
they get mad about it what's interesting
about this
is that if you go into the social media
hallways where this is reverberating
there are thousands of people who are
tweeting things like
my respect for kirk cousins just
skyrocketed finally somebody said it now
here's an athlete i can finally agree
with
it's not just this one-sided thing there
are countless masses
of non-maskers or of champions of the
non-mask who are now
rallying behind the quote it's we can't
fall into thinking that just because you
and i wear masks that everyone does it's
kirk cousins is not being torn apart
unilaterally for this quote in fact in
some circles he's been championed
kyle brandt here on the rich eisen show
one of the quartet on good morning
football every day
on nfl network and now the host of uh
10 questions with kyle brandt uh the
ringer and spotify is how you can get
that
great chat with rudd paul rudd last week
i mean he is one of the most delightful
human beings on the planet as you know
uh and i did not know that story about
him with
neil diamond would you please care to um
reveal that for those who might not have
heard that story that he got from paul
yeah the great paul rudd as many actors
did started some jobs that he wasn't
really thrilled with and he used to be a
dj
uh primarily at bar mitzvah's bat
mitzvahs
but he said he did one 40 year old
birthday party and part of his
obligations
as the dj is to do a little table work
to work the room to have make sure
everyone's having a nice time
so he played a little wang chung and
stepped away from the dj booth and he
said that by
some coincidence neil diamond was an
attendee at this party
so he walks up to neil diamond and says
uh mr diamond
are you having fun tonight and he said
yes i am and he said
well more importantly are you wang and
chung tonight
and neil diamond without blinking
says well i always try to wang chung
anytime i go out to a party it's very
important and
it just dead pans it total badass
does not miss a beat it was it was the
perfect uh
gary payton to sean camp alley-oop from
the guy who would become brian fantana
and ant-man
to the guy who sings forever in blue
jeans that's history right there
oh my gosh just fantastic
never thought there would be and that's
again that's why
that's why pod like yours is great and
why i'm sure again
simmons was attracted to the whole
concept is that to have paul rudd neil
diamond wang chung
and uh and djing all in one story that
is uh that's what
that's the good stuff right there oh
that's the greatest you know
um and so who uh is coming up on your
pod
well so we've done aaron rodgers batted
lead off yes
uh then we had tyron matthew then paul
rudd and out kirk cousins
and now we're into kind of parts unknown
rich you understand this
i've told you this for years i i think
you still have one of if not the best
book shows in the industry every time
i'm invited to come on
i'm like what did did daniel day-lewis
pull out or something like that does
that spot open up so you get the deal
here
right and now i'm just we we have an
episode due next wednesday and we have
none recorded and nobody booked
oh i'm sorry i'm out there casting the
nets and chumming the waters okay
so uh if you booked the starting
quarterback for the chicago bears week
one who would that be
i think it's going to be mitch of course
it is come on you and i both know it is
come on here's why it might not be i i
got it i got a thought on this rich and
hear me on this gets into the psyche of
bears fans and also of matt and aggie
the question there's two questions one
who's gonna start of course but then the
big question is they get prepared to
play detroit week one
how long is the leash here when does the
shepherds hook come out
i mean we have seen starting guys start
week one and be benched at halftime
if mitch trubisky starts and let's say
they lose the detroit let's say he
doesn't play great
is there already a fervor in chicago
because this is no ordinary backup
quarterback this is the guy with the
statue who makes miracles when he comes
off the bench
i think if foles wins the job
i don't think there's a clamoring for
mitch even a full struggle the bears
fans have seen mitch they know what he
is and what he isn't
but if mitch wins it there's a very
small margin of error before the put in
the statue guy off the sideline comes in
that question is going to be just as
important as who starts
but if we're if we're talking uh and we
are obviously talking about
we're talking about um what's easiest
to start with and then not go and then
what's most difficult
to pull the plug on
obviously it's more difficult to pull
the plug on mitchell
than it is on folds and it's much easier
to um to start uh
foals in regards to okay this is
uh a guy who won the super bowl and
we're gonna try and win football game
we're going with a guy who gives us the
best chance to win
but if it's difficult most difficult to
pull the plug on trubisky you can't do
it prior to week one you just flat out
can't i think that the bears still
deep down whether it's ryan pace i don't
know if it's maggie anymore
but it's ryan pace or it's you know uh
the ghost of papa bear i don't know what
it is but they are just
still hoping against hope that mitchell
trubisky
the guy that took such a major leap
forward in the year that nagy won coach
of the year
for it they're hoping that guy's still
there and that they cannot they cannot
say let's just go with nick foles right
here
i i don't think that's that's the case
kyle that's that's
it could be pace it could be george
hallas but
the the case for foals here to win the
job
is naggy saying screw it i'm done i i
did not draft mr bisky
i was i was in the chief's room when
they took my homes when they took
trubisky treviski is
i married into this one this is my
stepchild i love him
but i am not mr bisky's father this is
this is not the guy i drafted and i'm
not messing around this year i'm not
doing eight and eight i'm not doing nine
in seven
i brought fools here because i got a
history with him and i'm done with mitch
if if he says that i could i could i
could understand it and he said i don't
care who they drafted i wasn't here when
it happened i'm going with my guy
that's full shot and i i think it would
make sense for nagi
you know it's interesting kyle just to
bring up uh yeah
once again here you know that fournette
getting released
and then went through waivers completely
um
the jaguars had a shot at mahomes in
watson too you know
i just like the bears and the bears
getting so much grief i just don't know
if again it's
chicago is a different media market than
obviously duval county
but uh would the bears take fournette do
you think
what do you think i don't think so i i
it's it's fascinating to me man
rich that that fournette is sitting at
home right now i mean
the guy had more yards than dalvin cook
last year he's 25.
he was i think he's one of the five or
six best college running backs i've ever
seen what he did to auburn on that
saturday was a hilarious display
and he's been productive and now nobody
wants them i don't think the bears are
interested
because i don't think the montgomery
injury is that bad and i think they're
going to do some creative things in the
meantime and i just don't think they're
into that business
i just these running backs man if
leonard fournette was around
in 1991 he'd be getting 30 carries a
game and all the money in the world and
he'd be celebrating and now it's
unless you do crazy magical things like
mccaffrey or derek henry it's just not
happening and
all these guys saquon nick chubb all
these guys coming down the pipe camaro
obviously
the teams are looking at him like yeah
we just saw a super bowl in which the
two running backs were damien williams
and raheem mostert so
we're just getting a little cramp in our
check writing hand right now and i get
it
but now that he's gone through waivers
he is one would say dirt cheap
you know who would take i should i think
she'll take steelers
steelers should grab him right now i
love it steelers should grab him
exactly i mean the titans already have
derek henry
and and you know uh that that
i don't know uh maybe i guess that he
could take the carries from henry to
make sure he doesn't get but henry's the
type of guy is like
give me give me that 20th give me that
30th carry because i'm tougher
i'm tougher and you're weaker because
i've given you all i've gotten for 20
and i'm going to get stronger now
that fournette to me in pittsburgh when
it's going to get cold
and you need to make sure that big ben
isn't throwing it 70 yards in the air
and it's touchdown and all of a sudden
they're back on the field against the
ravens right
or if big ben isn't uh for summer if big
ben does suffer the same fate as say
eli and then phillip last year and
that's the
two quarterbacks he's associated with
for good reason they drafted together
that there is a diminishing return
factor
for ben certainly coming off of that
injury fournette with connor and the
rest of that crew
that's the old school steelers stuff
with the new school stuff that they're
doing and that defense
i think fournette would put them in a
great
spot and i think the fan base would go
crazy for it that's where i'm going
with him can i tell you something rich
we're getting to the point of the year
where we start to make your
divisional predictions your super bowl
predictions
i i got i got a special special feeling
about pittsburgh this year i i i'm in
i'm going to go big on pittsburgh in my
part in my predictions
i think they're going to do really
special things is that next week for
next week you're keeping that yeah we
usually well i mean
and good morning football we do it the
day of kickoff so it'd be next thursday
when we come out and we say this team is
going to win and this day
i i very well may come out in a
roethlisberger or tj watch jersey that
day
that's what we call a tease all right
before i let you go kyle uh i'd like to
spend just a couple minutes on our poll
question here chris brockman asked the
poll question of kyle brandt of good
morning football and ten questions with
kyle branford
my man it is the 56th birthday today of
keanu reeves
what's his best movie point break speed
john wick the matrix ah this is a great
question
i i i celebrate the man's empire catalog
i'm the guy who's seen
little buddha johnny mnemonic the lake
house
uh i remember he was an apollo abdul
music video they're all great
here's the answer here's my answer to
the question yes i think that the best
movie if i'm gonna go by the letter of
the law the best movie
is the matrix however the best keanu
reeves experience
at the canner reeves film festival is
definitely
definitely his role as johnny utah in
point break that
is the tour de force 1991
it's in a way like his rookie year he
just got
pulled up to the majors in 91 before
that he was doing little appearances in
parenthood
he shared the screen in bill and ted and
then 91 is his rookie year in the big
leagues up from
aaa and him and angelo pappas the great
gary busey out looking over the
hollywood hills and just going at it
just
chewing up scenery it is as good as
1990s cinema gets i will say
point break in a runaway 100 pure
adrenaline where do things currently
rank right there
love it chris point break is third right
now at 20 percent
the matrix is going to win this speeds
at the bottom 13
we are neck and neck right now with over
5 000 votes
the matrix 34 john wick
33.2 wow
rich i think i think the movie that you
have not seen my personal guess you said
you hadn't seen what is that
i think it's john wick okay what do you
think it is chris brockman what do you
got
there's no way you've missed point break
or the matrix in no way
chris what do you think you've never
seen jurassic park kind of in the s
i think you haven't seen speed by the
way
haven't seen speed i might have seen
speed the most out of the way
that's i'm going matrix to the point to
the point where i even gave speed to a
whirl
wow one of the worst the worst sequels
of all cruise control okay
not good cruise control that's right
cruise control
that's right by the way on the boat my
god
uh all right i don't mean to disappoint
you
but as you know chris i rarely see the
movie that you expect me to see the most
i have never seen point break oh my god
this is still my heart i know i'm so
sorry to disappoint you
look at tj jefferson you would love it
you would love it so much and swayze is
so cool and anthony keatis is there
it's just it's an awesome machismo pack
sausage it's so good mcginley's in it
like he is
fantastic it's your damn act together
thank you mr jones i appreciate that
the closing credits of the film are the
the band rat plays over it's not even
round and round it's like deep in their
catalog it's so
it's so 1991 richard hurts i know and i
know you were loving life in 91
no i please i was a year out of college
um
i never saw it and um i i need to fill
that uh
that hole in my resume please do it but
bigelow directed
i hear you yeah i hear you but i can't
watch it with my kids like
filling the sand hole with my watching
with my children watching with your kids
yeah i know all right very good uh i'm
sorry uh to everybody out there don't
mean to disappoint
uh play play uh to play kyle brandt out
our new favorite drop from uh jerry
jones will you please i think he'll
enjoy this
here we go mike this is from uh the
other day you get that no hang on
mike how do you not have it ready you
have it ready you've been playing it as
a non-sequitur 15 times
because i edited it for that second drop
so okay
i can't do it quick enough sorry rich do
you have it or not kyle's busy let's go
i don't have it i do not have it
available you had it ready
literally what do you got some sort of i
edited it for the second drop i'd have
to re-edit it again
do you have jj watts saying let's play
some tags
[Laughter]
challenge have you watched did you watch
ultimate tag did you yeah as soon as i
watched after we talked and he says it
exactly like that and he seems to say it
26 times before the first commercial
break it's awesome
okay all right kyle i'm sorry mike del
tufo's had that drop
literally ready he's played it already
four times today point so
he changed the entry point kyle he's
letting you know what's going on
though twofold cannot see the matrix
apparently
we'll just have to get it ready for you
next week thanks for coming on and i
look forward to having you join us uh
the show uh on a uh a frequent basis sir
thank you
the rich eisen showed the speeding bus
that always stays above 50.
i appreciate it
[Laughter]
well done kyle you take care of yourself
that's kyle brent uh
at kyle brandt on twitter 10 questions
with kyle brandt from the ringer in
spotify